[Music]
well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages as they come in time
then to see what is making the headlines
with the editor of the sheffield star
nancy fielder and the author and
historian peter francapan who we have
nancy's coming i'm told peter uh more
from both of you in just a moment but uh
first of all let's take a look at the
front pages the metro leading on the
prime minister's one trillion pound plan
to reach net zero carbon emissions by
twenty fifty that's also on the front
page of the daily mail which describes
the plan as a green gamble
the guardian reports experts are
dismissing the long-awaited strategy
saying it falls short on ambition and
funds
meanwhile only one in three care home
residents have received their covert
booster jab that's according to the
telegraph
the sun urges its readers to go and have
their extra jabs when they receive the
invitation
the eye leads with an exclusive as cases
rise the government scientific advisers
they say are meeting less often from
once a week to once a month
and the financial times reporting that
the chancellor rishi sunak will cut
taxes on bank profits in next week's
budget speech as he tries to keep the
city of london competitive post-brexit
set the budget already goodness uh nancy
fielder and peter francapan are both
here welcome to both of you nancy good
to see you um peter let's start with you
then daily mail the big reveal today uh
depending who you speak to this is the
most detailed plans of any uh g7 or g20
if you speak to other people a country
in the world so clearly they've gone a
long way um but it will be costly as the
daily mail points out
well it's 2 000 pages that have been
dropped this evening so it's going to
take a while to go through them you know
as always with any government uh the
devil is in the detail uh the big
challenge i think with this particular
uh announcement is that uh it sort of
seems like it's half fudge that there's
a lot of unproven technology that's
going to be relied on and although boris
johnson has been busy going to see asset
managers trying to work out the way in
which um contributions are going to be
made from the private sector to help pay
for this
is one thing and then as quite a few of
the newspapers are pointing out uh
there's going to be a tax vacuum because
as more and more cars become electric
for example there's going to be road tax
decline of of about 40 billion pounds
and the juggling up of how the uh the
numbers will work is something that i
think is is quite interesting and it's
revealing i think that there's not a
single comment from anybody in the
treasury or from rishi sunak this
evening about how this is going to be
funded and whether it's a sensible thing
to be doing given where we are with
public public finances yes and the daily
telegraph picking up on the on the
treasury part new taxes necessary to
reach net zero uh as you pointed out
this great vacuum um you know maybe
taxing roads uh you know who knows where
it lend up or ultimately taxing
electricity although not yet also
suggestions that the treasury hasn't put
his hand in its pocket enough to um
throw forward this heat pump idea uh
just 90 000 homes over the three years
which is roughly what's being done now
and so on ambition um as i said many
suggesting this really is the most
detailed of any g20 nation
but still some in the labour party
suggesting it's still not quite
ambitious enough nancy
well absolutely it's not just the labour
party i think once this has been
absorbed and the details been gone
through there will be an awful lot of
people saying it's not enough but let's
be positive this is a huge step forward
it is ambitious and we have got to be
ambitious we all know the climate crisis
that we're facing and it is good that
the government is doing something and
i'm not convinced personally that it is
enough and actually this is going to be
another interesting one isn't it so
taxes taxes well tax promises have been
broken it seems like fairly easy to
break these days for this government but
if we're going to be serious about this
we have all individually got to take
action as well as the big businesses and
governments owning it so it will be very
interesting one to watch and see how
this goes down with individuals does
everybody want electric cars they're
still very expensive
the pumps are difficult
to access aren't they not everybody's
got a huge garden to put one in so
massive massive implications on all
sorts of levels with this yes and the
suggestion is they'll work with industry
to bring down the cost of both electric
cars and heat pumps which means
everybody just sits in their hands and
waits till they become cheaper surely i
mean that's sort of the natural the
natural way of it the guardian uk's net
zero plans fall short on ambition and
funds uh despite the fact as we heard
from the uh the energy minister today
um
they're driving this uh this non-zero
emission road vehicles off the roads by
2040 new petrol and diesel cars uh also
by 2030 uh troubling the rate of new
tree planting by the end of the
parliament you know to become a global
leader in deploying green techs in the
future um you know developing carbon
sinks and so on there's there's really a
lot in these peter if you suggest it's
2000 pages dropping tonight
there is a lot there is a lot in there
and in fact many um
campaigners actually did welcome a lot
of uh what was said today
well look i think it's great you know i
mean i think we all as you rightly say
anna that we've got to we've got to
confront the climate crisis um and so
all steps are good i just think that
we've also got to think about the timing
obviously this is announced 10 days
before cop 26 when
public attention is going to be focused
on the climate so it's a good
opportunity but you know this is also
the the question is always in politics
is about timing you know we've just
taken on 400 billion 400 pounds rather
of national debt because of furlough and
the crisis of covid and so the question
is you know not not should we do it it's
it's can we do it and can we do it right
now you know so i think that the the
cost of photovoltaic cells of clean
energy has fallen very dramatically in
over the last 10 or 15 years you know
there are all sorts of opportunities
coming towards us we've got to take them
seriously we do do have to invest in
them but you know this is also a
question of bandwidth you know is this
going to be implemented from the
government in which case what do we do
with inflation what do we do with jobs
and furlough what do we do with the
regeneration of the high street you know
so the government is is fighting lots of
battles at the same time and you know
one gets the impression that boris quite
like a disaster to move from one to the
next but the key is to finish the job
right so this the worry is that this is
a starting point it's a salvo that gets
us talking about it but we've got to
make sure that it gets followed through
the uh the the net zero uh scrutiny
group in the houses of parliament set up
by the conservative steve baker who we
know from previous groups obviously and
the uh planet south mp craig mckinley uh
craig mckinley on the radio this evening
suggesting how will i how will i sell
this to my constituents um they'll get a
tepid radiator out of their heat pump
which they didn't want the electric car
which stands on the full court very
expensive they're still paying off that
they that they didn't want uh well they
look at other countries around the world
like indonesia and the philippines doing
not a lot and still producing coal how
do i sell it to the person who's sitting
there feeling poorer and colder and and
that is a point for many people this is
a global effort if the uk leads the way
you you are a small fish in a big pond
of effort nancy
absolutely and this is the problem with
the climate crisis actually we all want
it to be better but not many of us are
really putting our weight in doing what
needs to be done and when it comes to
money a lot of us are far far worse off
or in much more precarious employment
than we were before covered so those
points are absolutely valid however if
we're about to go and we are into a
massive conference where actually the
real challenge for the government is to
persuade the huge countries the
china's and the americas of this world
that they need to do more than we have
got to be seen to take it seriously as
well this is a massive i mean this is
not easy it's not often that i feel
sorry for boris johnson but actually he
has got to be seen to be taking this
seriously and as individuals to some
extent we have got to suck it up and get
on with it but it is his job to make it
as easy and as accessible and as
chief i suppose for everybody because
individuals just don't really want to
make sacrifices any of us do us even to
save the planet we're not willing to do
it otherwise we would have done a lot of
this already so the cheaper we can make
the electric cars and the easier it can
be to change our gas points and get rid
of them that is the only way to success
so there is a long way to go but i think
this is a positive start
well our climate change correspondent
got a question to the to the uh excuse
me chinese today uh they suggested they
didn't really need to be lectured by the
uk government they have their own plans
and will stick to them which is
presumably their net zero promise of
2060 and uh peak emissions by 2030 some
hoping it might be coming down to 2025.
president putin we heard last week 2060
as well um are you feeling optimistic
about cop 26 and the sort of more
binding agreements to take paris forward
because
you know the the mood music isn't
entirely singing i think peter
well i think to sort of paraphrase her
majesty the queen you know we don't know
who's turning up yet um you know it
looks like xi jinping's not going to
come nor's putin and um i think that's
quite revealing these big these
conferences tend to announce things in a
fanfare and they're not to deliver so
the paris agreements there's not a
single country in the g20 that has kept
to its own agreements uh not just the uk
but none of the none of the g20
countries so you know i think it's right
that we should be leading on this uh i
suspect that there will be a lot of
nations in the world that will free ride
that won't meet their emissions and will
keep public polluting and choose to grow
their economy instead of working over
the what the long-term consequences are
you know to your point about about mps
saying how do they sell it to their
constituents you know that's their job
you know as an mp as well as to be
persuading what the long-term and the
short-term future of the country is you
know how do you persuade people to pay
their tax money to get to get hospitals
you know law courts everything else done
there's vested interest that we all have
to function as a community together and
energy poverty is something that's
really significant in this country no we
don't need to just remind that the price
of gas has pushed businesses bust but
that's going to come through to the
customers in the last part of this year
with at a very substantial level and and
you know fuel poverty is a real thing in
the united kingdom so moving away to
more renewable sources that might be
cheaper i think it's it's it's all to be
welcome but it just needs to be joined
up thinking and joined up action yes i
think craig mckinley was suggesting that
nuclear would be a better fit rather
than chasing heat pumps or indeed
hydrogen which is one of those
technologies that we're not sure what
the payoff will be and just quickly um
nancy your paper reflecting on prince
william's earth shot prize
for the people of sheffield imagine what
we could do if we'd won one million
pounds absolutely so this is this is
also our front page which hasn't been
created yet because of the football but
this is just a fantastic fantastic
charity in sheffield called called food
works that with three vans and hundreds
of volunteers saves more food from the
landfill and feeds hungry bellies in
sheffield than the whole of milan so
milan with a prize in this one charity
doing it here in sheffield and i think
it's recycling something like 500 tons
of food a year is absolutely incredible
and there is some really good stuff
going on so there i know it's terribly
depressing but there's some fantastic
people who need shout outs and it's all
voluntary yeah it needs to be scaled up
by the sound of it you get on that
plenty what's still to come in the next
part of our program nhs bosses calling
for ministers to urgently implement plan
b plus winter covered restrictions to
curb surging case numbers back with that
after this
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now the editor of
the sheffield star nancy fielder and the
author and historian peter francopan
welcome back to both of you uh covid
let's talk covid guardian uh well it's
you know it's in many of the newspapers
actually let's start with the guardian
nancy nhs chiefs urge plan b plus a
mid-covered surge as we learn from the
eye that the scientists are only meeting
once a month now as infections rise
what's to be done
well perhaps some of the basic things
actually we're told we could continue
doing if we wanted to i mean sort of
keeping a social distance and wearing
face masks washing your hands we all
remember these things don't we but
they've gone away it feels very much
like we kind of felt that the vaccine
was a superhero that was coming in to
save us with double jabs some people are
not triple jumped and it's made us
absolutely immune to anything and
actually as we all know it's not true
but we don't seem to be doing anything
about it if you get on a bus or a train
i've been on plenty of trains this week
and actually hardly anybody's wearing
face masks you go into really crowded
spaces and people aren't wearing face
masks these very basic things that we're
also used to doing for quite a long time
we've instantly put to one side but then
the government said it was up to us and
clearly if it's up to us we're not doing
it right so it surely is time for
somebody to intervene here yeah well yes
i mean does that mean we we need to be
told we're masked they are in france in
spain
in italy uh where the cases are a
fraction of hours obviously uh daily
telegraph once again suggesting um that
really it's the booster job we need to
be pushing forward with and the
12 to 15 jab and you know the government
has has the government over relied
simply on the vaccine as the way out of
this we see waning don't we and uptake
issues you know we're no longer leading
the way in europe on this peter
well i think if you all the front pages
make the point they're covering the
story quite heavily that you know gp's
are at absolute maximum capacity so only
a third of care home
uh residents have been jabbed and it's
because
and 12 to 15 year olds aren't getting
the job now too because gps don't have
enough time and resource and you know
you'll remember only only last week the
health secretary was saying that gps
need to pull their finger out and work
harder which set off um not surprisingly
uh the medic the medics in the uk saying
that they've done not a bad job in the
last two years under very difficult
circumstances
you know i do think that the mask issue
is something which we need to come back
to we've got six million people almost
on hospital waiting lists and the
hospitals will get full um very quickly
in the next coming weeks not just with
covert but with flu and with other
illnesses too and that will stretch us
back to where we were again so you know
there does need to be i think some some
much
tougher direction from from on top to
tell us how we should be behaving
yeah i mean some suggest just quickly
nancy that people have had enough of you
know all the restrictions is that true
or is it because the government told us
that
as you mentioned it it it's all optional
i think people have had enough have been
locked down and kept away from each
other but what actual harm does women
face must do is such a simple thing that
actually we are really really stupid to
stop doing the very basics which would
then be able to protect the freedoms
that we all want
it just seems a bit daft to throw it all
away and
we won't do it unless we're told to do
it i think we've got the evidence of
that we saw what happened at the
beginning didn't we